how might the international relocation of
species
affect the future environment of selection?
for example
sweet corn in europe, european diaspora, no
wolves in Britain, a zoo animal escapes internationally?
I can give you a very good answer to that
question.
A group at the university of arizona are working
on a theory
called the portmanteau traveling biota theory.
The portmanteau traveling biota theory
is based on the idea that humans and their
domesticates exerted a reciprocal
influence on one another's evolution.
And that when different populations of humans
spread to different parts of the world, it's
not just this
bunch of people
moving over to this other part of the world,
they bring with them their portmanteau biota.
that means their diseases, that means their
domesticates their cultivars, their crops,
their pests and vermin.
all of that travels with them.
and it's interesting because there are strong
coevolutionary pressures, which have arisen
in the course of human evolution from domesticates.
a good example would be lactate persistence,
and its spread.
it's obvious that if you can metabolize lactose
you can break that down,
and use it as a dietary sugar, you can liberate
huge numbers of calories, for very little
effort.
all you need to do is have dairy.
so it's not a surprise that lactose persistence
spread
concomitantly with dairying culture, with
the spread of cows.
so where you get one, you get the
other.
this is one of the earliest examples of
an unambiguous culture gene co-evolution.
but don't forget we also did
things to cows which affected their evolution.
so domestication
was very much a two-way street, the same is
true of crops.
All this nonsense people have about
they can't digest this that and the other
substance, like gluten.
well it turns out that yes, some people
can digest it, other people have a
harder time digesting it.
Gluten sufficiency might actually relate to
a history
of how we co-evolve with respect to certain
domesticates, some of which may have
produced foodstuffs that were very rich in
gluten, like wheat.
so it's clear that there is this tremendous
coevolutionary pressure.
that humans have all not just in isolation,
they evolve in relation to their surrounding
ecology, and they've exerted reciprocal effects
on the composition of that ecology. and the
way they influence the selective
pressures acting on specific species, through
artificial selection,
in turn influenced the sets of relationships
that existed between those species and other
species which meant you could
have these massive impacts on the surrounding
ecology, as a consequence of the action of
human
domestication pressures.
so it's a hugely important question, and it's
one for which data is being gathered, in terms
of being able to comprehensively test this
portmanteau biota model.
and actually there's a
very good paper published in the journal evolutionary
psychological sciences.
it's called plants parasites and people.
and they look at this very mysterious association
which seems to exist between the presence
of coniferous plants, and perennial
plants, which are present in more northerly
latitudes, and parasite burden, and k selection
in
humans.
and what they found is that the presence of
evergreen plants, verse perennial plants which
drop their leaves onto
the ground once a year, like oak, woody dicots.
the presence of these strongly mediates the
association between the prevalence of parasites
in the environment, and your level of life
history
speed, so how slow your life history is.
and it turns out that the reason the plants
mediate this
association is because what's happening is
the plants are engaging in chemical warfare
against
parasites in the soil, pushing the numbers
of those parasites down, which in turn releases
humans from
a major source of r selection, i-e disease
outbreaks that cause unpredictable mortality
and morbidity,
which is the major factor selecting fast life
history.
so where you have
all these plants you have a strong coevolutionary
pressure.
the plants are doing something
for humans, which means the humans are more
likely to do things that are going to encourage
the growth
of these plants.
so that's a good example of this reciprocal
effect, which is mediated through the effect
of a plant on parasites, and the downstream
effect that that's had on human
adaptive landscape in these regions.